hey dr. Berg here in this video I want
to share with you some solutions to gout
gout can be very very painful it's a
type of arthritis that usually goes
right to your big toe okay and what's
happening is you have this this protein
metabolism problem and you form
monosodium urate hydrate crystals try to
say that five times fast and these
crystals build up in the joint and they
start creating a lot of inflammation you
will also have a high uric acid and and
both of these are incomplete or
undigested protein that kind of turns
into these little crystals it's really a
kidney problem and use it comes from
consuming too many cooked foods when you
live on cooked foods whether it's
pasteurized foods or canned foods or
just overly cooked things you start to
destroy the function of the kidney and
your liver okay and these are the organs
that help process and clean up proteins
and if it's spilling over into the
joints you're going to get go so here's
some things to avoid number one organ
meats okay that will flare it up like
liver and definitely kidney or if you
have I don't know brain things like that
don't consume those coffee caffeine Cola
and grains will all aggravate that okay
especially if you sat down and you have
a lot of huge cooked meat this big piece
of protein that would be bad for the
gout what to do you want to consume
foods very very high in potassium and
vegetables okay that's going to clean
out the kidney so you want to do huge
salads and you want to do more raw foods
and less cooked foods alright so maybe
you want to steam your vegetables but
don't overly cook it also cherries are
really good we don't know why but
they're really good for gout alright go
ahead and try these actions and I will
see you in the next video hey guys thank
you so much for watching please click
the subscribe button and I will see you
in the next video